der Krieg den Russland gegen die Ukraine
führt hat ja auch Auswirkungen auf die
Lebensmittelpreise weltweit schließlich
ist die Ukraine normalerweise einer der
größten getreideexporteure ja um die
Ausfuhren sicherzustellen da gab es seit
Juli letzten Jahres ein Ukraine
getreideabkommen aus dem Russland sich
jetzt aber zurückgezogen hat auf einem
ernährungsgipfel der Vereinten Nationen
hat der UN-Generalsekretär Russland
gestern zu einer Rückkehr zum
getreideabkommen aufgerufen
Lebensmittelpreise haben nämlich
besonders zerstörerische Auswirkungen
für gefährdete Länder die darum kämpfen
ihre Bevölkerung zu ernähren
unser Topthema heute ausbleibende
Lieferungen steigende Preise wie die
weltweite Nahrungsmittelkrise bewältigen
was kann die EU der Blockade Russlands
entgegensetzen das Topthema jetzt im ZDF
Morgenmagazin
Lösungen für die Ernährungskrise darum
geht es heute bei einem Treffen auf
EU-Ebene die EU Agrarminister erörtern
wie die Ernährungssicherheit
gewährleistet werden kann darüber
spreche ich jetzt mit
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister James die
mir von den Grünen aus Brüssel
zugeschaltet schönen guten Morgen
guten Morgen Frauen haben willst
russland hat ja gerade entschieden die
Schwarzmeer getreide-initiative auch
getreideabkommen genannt zu beenden
welche Auswirkungen wird das haben
es geht gar nicht so sehr um die Menge
des wird durch gute Ernten vielleicht
anderswo kompensiert werden können aber
es geht auch um die Preise des führt
dazu dass die Preise jetzt durch die
Decke schießen könnten und gerade für
die ärmeren Länder
Getreidepreise da nicht teurer werden
und die Bezahlbarkeit schwieriger wird
das hat Auswirkungen auf Stabilität das
hat auswirkend auf den Hunger das ist
genau das was Putin möchte
dass wir den schwarzen Peter zugeschoben
bekommen das würde an den Sanktionen
liegen das ist aber nicht der Fall es
gibt nur einen einzigen Grund das ist
der Feige Angriffskrieg Russland so auf
die Ukraine der muss enden wenn es noch
einen weiteren Grund gibt warum man die
Ukraine jetzt unterstützen muss mit
allem was wir können damit die Ukraine
ihre territorial Integrität
zurückgewinnt und Russland versteht dass
das nicht geht dann haben wir hier ein
weiteren
wie reagiert darauf
indem wir weiterhin Solidarität mit der
Ukraine zeigen und Russland deutlich
machen dass ihre Strategie uns zu
endsolidarisieren nicht funktioniert
auch ihre Hoffnung dass wir über
Parteien wie die AFD oder wie die Frauen
national über andere Verbündete von
Putin bei uns schwach werden wird nicht
funktionieren wir werden stark bleiben
und an der Seite der Ukraine stehen und
gleichzeitig müssen wir dafür sorgen
mich natürlich auf der Stichwort
Ernährungssicherheit also konkret die
Getreide Ausfuhren wie geht's da weiter
das wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen ja das
wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen wenn sie
mich lassen und gleichzeitig müssen wir
dafür sorgen dass wir die alternativen
exportrouten Stärken der hat die
Europäische Union ja einiges erreicht
aber klar ist natürlich auch es braucht
jetzt eine klare Festlegung welche
Alternativroute die beste ist was nicht
akzeptabel ist wenn Nachbarstaaten die
Grenze zu Ukraine schließen damit helfen
sie nur Vladimir Putin
Ukraine Präsident selenski gefordert die
EU ja zu dem auf ihre Grenzen für
Agrarprodukte zu öffnen also vielleicht
für die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
kurz zu Erklärung die EU-Kommission
hatte Einschränkungen für Getreide
Importe aus der Ukraine ja verlängert
weil Landwirte aus östlichen EU-Ländern
ein Preisverfall durch die ukrainische
Konkurrenz befürchten wie geht man damit
jetzt weiter um die eigenen Landwirte
schützen oder die Einfuhr von wichtigen
Getreide sichern
ist ein lösbares Problem mit dem wir die
Produkte aus der Ukraine rausschafft und
dahin wo sie hin sollen nämlich an
europäische Häfen und von dort dann
weiter verschafft an den globalen Süden
man könnte die Zollabfertigung in
europäischen Häfen machen was jedenfalls
nicht geht ist das Nachbarländer zu
Recht die Solidarität in Anspruch nehmen
aus dem Krisenmechanismus gibt es ja
Geld für unsere Nachbarn in Polen und in
anderen Ländern müssen unterstützen wir
aber dann gleichzeitig noch die Grenze
schließen für ukrainische Produkte das
kann ich funktionieren das schwächte
Ukraine stärkt werden die mir putin ist
das Gegenteil von dem was wir machen
sollten wir sind gerne bereit mit Polen
das werde ich heute hier sagen nach
Wegen zu schauen wie wir sicherstellen
können dass das Ukraine aus dass das
Getreide aus der Ukraine dort ankommt
was ankommen soll es will im übrigen
auch die Ukraine ja wir bleiben beim
Thema Lebensmittel aber ja ein anderer
Aspekten anderes Thema als
bundesernährungsminister hatten sie ja
vorgeschlagen fernsehwer bung für
ungesunde Lebensmittel die an Kinder
adressiert ist zu Kernzeiten zu
verbieten um Kinder so vor falsche
Ernährung zu schützen die FDP will das
Blockieren fordert statt pauschaler
Verbote mehr auf Bewegung und Aufklärung
zu setzen und jetzt
und jetzt rate ich zu einem Blick in die
Koalitionsvereinbarung da steht das drin
ich bin koalitionstreue als Vertreter
einer bürgerlichen Partei gilt für mich
das mal ein gegebenes Wort einhält ich
gehe davon aus es gilt für uns alle
übrigens ich kann laufen und Pfeifen
gleichzeitig ich gehe davon aus meine
FDP Kollegen können das auch also für
Bewegung für gesundes Essen in der
Schule und gleichzeitig Werbung für
Lebensmittel die viel zu viel zuckerfett
Salz enthalten für Kinder unter 14 Jahre
die das gar nicht beurteilen können
regulieren als das eine tun das andere
nicht lassen ich glaube das können die
Kollegen von der FDP auch
die mir war das zur weltweiten
Ernährungskrise und zum Werbeverbot in
Deutschland für ungesunde Lebensmittel
ganz herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch